salut a tous voila je vous avais annoncé
que je vais participer à une émission
qui s'appelle le grand oral diffusé ce
soir sur france 2 et documents a demandé
de décrire les petites chansons sur le
thème d'une déclaration d'amour à la
france comme je suis belge et où c'était
rigolo et documents différemment un truc
que dans ton style dans son univers et
donc on a enregistré l'émission
et puis la directrice de france
télévisions va dire effectivement c'est
vraiment dans ton style dans son univers
et effets du coup c'est rigolo parce que
on va te couper au montage
et moi je dis c'est rigolo parce que moi
de jour après jour des monts dvd de son
spectacle alors j'ai dit tiens si je
faisais cette chanson sur scène pour que
les gens puissent quand même l'entendre
et puis comme ça moi je pourrais essayer
de faire un montage où j'essaierai de
para group est alors voici donc ma
déclaration d'amour à la france
quand je t'ai vu la première fois
c'était lors d'une visite à cannes moi
qui viens d'un petit pays froids j'ai
tout de suite tombé sous son charme pitt
est bon vin montant
et notre idylle a commencé très vite on
a sauté le pas je suis
chez toi et j'ai quitté mon antique
royaume pour épouser mon hexagone
je pensais que ce qu'on a
était unique et passionné mais j'ai
découvert ce matin qu'en fait tu es là
nue
héros un des pays les plus visités par
les touristes du monde entier
et pout but en fait l'équipe prospeed la
terre entière de passe dessus
dans tous les
à chaque minute
epic ma mère et ma tante confondues
oui millions de
armoires
ça en fait des bus de chinois
delatour et
elle à saint-trop' la france et la [ __ ]
de lui
[Musique]
de toute façon j'allais te larguer moi
j'en pouvais plus pour être franche je
prêtais johnny hallyday
harang dur est comme une ombre
[Musique]
j'avais même prêté stromae
la rendu presque français j'avais même
envoyé liot dublin rendu
[Musique]
des années que tu fait des vannes sur
les belges que tu te paie notre tête
alors je suis allé en bretagne y'a plus
tel chrono que calais
pays des lumières soi-disant
je crois qu'il ya des pannes de courant
les seuls français que j'ai vu brillant
c'était des gilets jaunes en feu sur les
champs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voulais une blague sur les français
savent et c'est quoi la différence entre
un cancer est un politicien français un
cancer ça commence dans une cellule
alors qu'un politicien français ça finit
dans une cellule hôte a des qualités
pourtant tu es un des seuls pays sur
terre que thooris depuis 60 ans le
mariage posthume c'est super mais quand
on voit le temps qu'a mis
pour légaliser le mariage gay
11 il visiblement ici
au mieux être mort que d'être bd
si on faisait la paix enfin tu sais il
fut une époque où nos pays
nos faisait qu'un où on est et
compatriote où normalement les chefs
d'état ne voulait pas d'entrer en
seconde et où les gens n'avaient pas le
droit de s'acheter la coupe du monde
monde
[Applaudissements]
plus on aime quelqu'un m'a dit il faut
quand le flat avait dit molière
alors ce soir je crois que par ses mots
j'ai prouvé que la france je t'aime à ma
manière
groupe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]